the president has tweeted from Singapore
that Larry Kudlow
who's 70 director of the National
Economic Council apparently according to
the president has had a heart attack and
is a Walter Reed Medical Center
receiving treatment at this hour that's
all we know when we find out more of
course we'll tell you right away bret
baier ankara special report and our
friend is on the scene live in singapore
for SI Brett what's it what's going on
there well Tucker I mean that was just a
real surprise to have the president
issue a tweet or send out a tweet with
breaking news about Larry Kudlow and
obviously our prayers were for him he's
at Walter Reed we're told by the
president don't have any more
information what's happening here is
were moments away from the greeting
between President Trump and Kim jong-un
at this Cappello resort on this this
island that's kind of separated from
downtown Singapore that both motorcades
have arrived and we're just waiting for
any moment the host TV to put out this
shot and there you see it
president Trump were told will come from
the right side and Kim Jong un from the
left and there will be a handshake which
will be probably the most photographed
in the world as you're looking at a
picture of Larry Kudlow still trying to
get some information about his status